what is the area of the figure so down
here we have this one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten sided
figure
and we want to know its area how many
square meters
does this figure cover and we have some
measurements that seems helpful
but what's not too helpful to me is i
don't know the special trick to find the
area of a ten-sided figure
so i've got to think about what i do
know and what i do know is the way to
find area of a rectangle so what i can
do
is i can see if i can find any
rectangles in here here's one rectangle
right there so i can find the area of
that part
then let's see if i can find any more
here's another
rectangle
so i can find the area of that part
we could call that one a rectangle or a
square
and then that leaves us with this last
part
which is again
a rectangle
so what we did is we broke this up or
decomposed it into three rectangles
and now if i find out how much space
this purple one covers the blue one and
the green one
if i combine those that would tell me
the area of the entire figure how much
space the entire figure covers
so let's start with this one right here
this one is three meters long
so we kind of divide that by three
meters
into three equal meters
and then we got a width of two meters
down here so just put that in half
so if we
draw those lines out
we can see
this top row is going to cover one
square meter two square meters three
square meters
and then there's two rows of that so
there's two rows
of three square meters
or a total of six square meters
this rectangle covers six square meters
so this part of the entire figure covers
six square meters
the next one our measurements are three
and a three
so it will have three rows of three
square meters or nine square meters
and then finally this purple one
has three meters and nine so we can say
it will have three rows
of nine or nine rows of three square
meters which is
27 square meters
so the area
of this purple section
it covers completely 27 square meters
the green covers nine square meters and
the blue covered six square meters
so if we combine all those areas all
those square meters of covers that will
tell us the area
of the entire figure so we have 6 square
meters
plus 9 square meters
plus 27
and we can solve that 6 plus 9 is 15
15 plus 27
let's see five ones and seven ones is
twelve ones
let's find some space up there
and
one ten and two tens or a ten and a 20
is 30
and 30 plus 12 is
42. so the area of the entire figure is
square
meters